So we're going to talk today about two
of the most significant episodes of part
two of the Quixote.
That'd be salts that mark a transition to,
uh,
that begin the sort of the down slope
of the novel as it moves towards its
conclusion.
It is a protracted combination and
finale consistent with the slower,
more deliberate pace of part two.
We will be meeting one character
from part one who reappears.
He ness the Pasa Monte under
the guise of master puppeteer,
uh,
master Peter.
And there will not only be
repetitions of episodes from part one,
but even repetitions of episodes
from part two within part two.
After the episodes that
I will discuss today,
three major new developments occur
first or don Quixote will sometimes
leave the center of the action to be
replaced by sanctuary.
Second,
that both don Quixote and
Sankyo become objects,
the object of amusement for frivolous
upperclass characters who have,
who have read part one and three,
that the protagonist would be surrounded
by many more characters than before.
The overarching theme of
the novel continues to be
this in Ganja as most of the
action is staged by internal authors.
Uh,
it is an action that is highly theatrical
and the props or backstage of the
skits are reveal to the reader either
during their performance or right after
the first of the two important episodes
is the one about don Quixote's descent
into Montesinos cave.
A truly remarkable to have the force and
one of the most brilliant scenes in the
western literary tradition.
So Montesinos Cave. This is, uh,
one of the principle episodes of part
two and arguably of the entire work
because it seems to engage
the main literary topics
and sources of the novel and
also,
uh,
provides a rare glimpse into the
inner workings of donkey hold.
This subconscious,
it is us as if we were looking behind the
scenes of the cohort or allowed to see
it reverse site.
Uh,
as we see the reverse side
of that painting within, uh,
Las Meninas that bellicose is working on,
it is also as,
as if we were allowed to dissect the,
um,
to dissect the protagonist
while he's still alive.
Then at first notice that this is
an adventure that Don Quixote six,
that he looks forward,
not one that is imposed on him by chance.
Like the encounters on the road or by
other characters who are scripting is
life.
As we have seen.
Sandstone Carrasco from the very beginning
is trying to script hold Hotez life
and there will be several other
internal authors doing that.
But this is not the case
at all. Is An episode, uh,
an adventure that don't
Quixote, uh, once, uh,
200 take and he tells this
scholar or the cousin, uh,
that he wants to do so and asks how
to get to want to see gnosis cave.
It is also an episode that
is a strictly, uh, Spanish,
uh,
and that seems to take Don Quixote
into the depths of the Spanish soil.
It is as if saying that these
kinds of fabulous events, uh,
also happen in Spain and
in the present a law,
as you will see, and I will speak
about the sources of the episode,
a descends into caves and so forth.
And, uh, uh, but this is one, uh,
that is based on us Spanish,
uh,
a tradition that is,
people knew about Montesinos
Cave and talked about it.
They exist and don't be hot.
They want it to go into them,
decided that he had to
have this, uh, adventure.
One way to see the episode as
flowing from Camacho's wedding,
which is the big episode proceeding.
It is true. It's connection with orbit.
The cousin or scholar who is their
guide is writing a Spanish of it and the
explanation given about the reverse of
Spain and their names is in the spirit of
the metamorphosis. This
scholar, uh, is, uh,
another satire of a
students and intellectuals,
uh,
like the one that we have seen in
the case of Sandstone Carrasco.
This is even more extreme.
This is a really ridiculous,
a scholar who,
uh,
is trying to find out who had
the first cold in history,
if you remember.
Uh,
and, uh, so I also said that in part two
of the Quixote Cervantes seems
to be signaling as his sources,
homer Virgil of it.
And as we shall see,
Dante as if claiming that his
work is they're worthy successor,
that he's in their league as it were.
In common parlance,
I will speak about Virgil
when we get to meet LTC Dora,
the character that you will meet and find
very amusing who is a version of Dido.
Now these descending to the cave
has antecedents in the Odyssey,
the need and the divine comedy of course.
Uh,
although there are also sources in Valerie
Grumman insists this is an very and
adventure on a higher literary level.
This is not just going back to
episodes in the chivalric romances,
but homer, Virgil, Dante,
uh,
there are of course also traditional
stories about going into caves in all
cultures. Uh, and in all literatures.
If you have read your American literature,
you see that in Tom Sawyer and
huckleberry Finn and so forth.
There are episodes where the characters
go into, into caves. But here,
I think the, the sources are
those that I mentioned, uh,
going down into the cave has of course,
deep psychological resonances having to
do with Don Quixote's sexuality and come
competently, uh, his fear of death.
As he enters the cave,
he has to walk away at the brambles
covering the entrance in actions that are
symbolic or reminiscent over deflowering.
And the black birds that fly away
in freight are clear in dimensions.
Intimations of death.
They are bad omens.
They have a kind of a Hitchcock like
air to beat. I mean, to modern readers,
they, uh, I'm sure remind
you of that very frightening.
Hitchcock film,
the birds
what donkey haughty experiences
in the cave is a dream.
And of course these alliances
with dream literature,
this is clear by his being
asleep when it's pulled back up.
And from the story he tells about falling
asleep when he sits down on the coiled
up rope within the cave,
don't get help.
He says that he wakes up from that sleep,
but it is obvious that he
awakens within the dream.
Now this is a dream within a dream.
Uh, another, uh, mirror effect.
What the dream allows is for
the untrammeled emergence
of Don Quixote's deepest
fears in the form of stories related
to his fantasies or drawn from his
fantasies.
It is as if he had been
administered a drug, a drug,
a truth serum,
or us if he had relaxed on
the psychoanalyst's couch
and allowed himself to free
associate
the story of good and dark.
Then Burma is drone from the
Corolla Carolingian cycle.
Remember that I mentioned the
various cycles of what you violated,
Romances and the epics and the Carol
Legion is from Charlie Maine and so forth.
They're drawn from the Charlie Carolingian
cycle and seems to have embedded not
only, uh, the fear of death,
but the fear of castration.
Uh,
all the characters except for Merlin are
from the balance of the Carolingian and
Arthurian Cycle.
King Arthur Charlemagne,
the characters are supposed to be
dead and everyone is in the morning.
And the procession is a,
is a kind of a mournful procession as
like a barrier dude underneath his body in
the story has his heart removed and
sent it to Bill Irma as a symbol of his
undying love. This is
the original story. He's,
he asked when he died,
who have this heart removed
and sent to his beloved here,
his castrated cadaver acid,
where appears as the statue of grazing
his own tomb and able to speak.
But the voracity of the story is
compromised or grotesquely guaranteed by
Montesinos inclination that he has had
to salt the heart so that it would so
that they will not rot and begin to smell.
This destroys the fantasy.
I mean,
if this great hero have is
how has his heart center,
his beloved one,
never thinks that this heart will
be subject to the laws of nature.
I mean, this is fantasy
world, but here, uh,
that fantasy is destroyed. And the
story, the voracity of the story,
in other words,
can be guaranteed.
But the fact that they have to salt it
so that it won't fill, that it won't rot
a natural laws threaten the
story's very similitude.
A jerk beef heart is not the same
as the heart that symbolizes love,
courage and masculinity and me sir,
the heart of course,
all of these connotations.
Uh,
so if you think of it as being made
of Jerky, beef, all of that, uh,
all of those connotations are
destroyed or become grotesque.
Although time is flexible within episode,
it effects on Flesh,
our present that is
invested in other aspects.
I say that the time is flexible.
Who was in the episode because how long
was Gnocchi halted down the scholar and
San Jose?
An hour at most he says three days and
then there is the issue of how long ago
the stories occurred
hundreds of years ago.
Yet these characters are, are, are there.
So a time within the,
within the story is,
is flexible as time tends to be,
as we know in dreams,
we know now from modern stories and dreams
that that stories that seem to take a
long time actually take a few seconds.
In a dream,
but a under that is this, this, this
compression that Freud talks about,
about her dream compressive
stories in very short time.
This is intimated here
and that, uh, uh, look,
the hottest has been there for three
days and say, oh, we're only an hour.
But the effect of time on flesh is,
is,
is evident.
Now these detail of the
effect of time on flesh, uh,
uh,
reveal some key holders own doubts
about the legitimacy of the chivalric
legends. I mean, remember this is
the story he himself is telling.
Uh, so, uh, if he, if,
if a story comes up in his subconscious
subconsciousness because he, he's,
he has doubts about the
legitimacy of this, of the, uh,
of the true legends,
their stories,
those of that you've got Rick
legends violate natural laws.
Hence they are fantastic
as other characters have
been telling him all along.
And all of this seems to
have had an effect on him.
Now, don't be haughty is
recognized as a great night,
a constant that began when with
sandstone care, Roscoe's revelation,
that of the existence of part one a.
And this is something that will happen
over and again in part two that he is
recognized as a great night. But in
this case by characters who succeed,
whose own existence is very,
very doubtful and that he himself will
doubt from now on by asking others
anxiously. Like, am I supposed
the roast master Peter's monkey?
If what happened in the cave was real
and by insisting that sanctuary believed
that it was real
striking deals with him,
I'd believe that if you believe the cave
of dizziness we shows and he's not that
sure about. So, uh,
their recognition that is the recognition
of his being a great night by these
characters is, is Harley, uh, an assurance
I am underlining this,
this doubts that the stories reveal
his own, uh, his own fantasies.
But the most disturbing part of the
story is the appearance of do scenario in
the guise of the ugly winch that central
tried to make him believe was his lady.
This is a,
okay,
we know from Freud Freud's great booked
interpretation of dreams that was
published in 1900,
uh,
that we talked about the remains of the
day. How a dream picks up elements from,
from the previous day.
And May it incorporates it into stories.
And this is sort of the
remains of the day. Uh,
now the appearance of this
wench convinced the sanctuary.
The Don Quixote is insane because
he was the author of that charade.
But it also shows to what extent
that episode of the three, uh,
peasant women,
uh,
has shaken donkey halters own beliefs
and probed deep into the sources of his
own desires for [inaudible] and,
oh,
he's invention of Gucci man,
this person [inaudible] who smells
of raw garlic, if you can remember,
uh,
she smelled of sweat in Sanchez
earlier story about her when you said,
I got next to her and she smelled a little
bit because she was pitching the hay
or whatever it was. Uh, this,
this person [inaudible] I
think this close to them.
Key holders own real desire for,
I don't sell or install the original Lucy,
Neha.
It seems to be the repressed desire
for a vulgar, physically strong,
sexually aggressive younger woman who is
the very opposite is the fact that the
is the core relative opposite
of his idealization of her.
The more vulgar this woman of his,
of his desires is,
the more idealized she
will become in his fantasy.
Also,
uh,
when he asked for a loan
by her in this hilarious,
hilarious part of the story.
The last thing you imagine if we do female
asking for a loan from be hot though,
uh,
which is going to be backed up by the way,
the guarantee is a, is an intimate, uh,
um, uh, uh, an inner garment
of Deucey nails. This is a very
elaborate, uh, underskirts of sorts.
It's going to be the guarantees. I mean,
these things are highly sexualized, but
donkey hot, the short two realities,
a g one six,
but he has only four left to give her.
Okay.
Uh,
this is a clear of his deep and repress.
Fear of sexual inadequacy.
Couldn't be clearer.
You don't have to be Freud.
Uh,
which may be the source of his heroic
fantasies is old feel sexually inadequate.
So he goes to imagine himself a young,
vigorous night who can go and
fight and seduce maintenance.
So Saint Joe's invention in the episode
of the enchanted we'll see now has dug
deep into donkey halters dreads and
into the source of his fantasies.
In this topsy turvy world of the cave,
there are eerie images of death.
Also,
I already mentioned the black birds
at the mouth of the cave dude Undark.
This cadaver posing as a statue on its
own sarcophagus is the areas of the mall
and the uncanny just it's,
it's an inversion.
The statue on a sarcophagus presumably
represents the body of the dead person
within it.
I'm sure you have been to
European cathedrals where
you go and you find all of
this sarcophagi guy and you'll see on
top the statue of the recumbent statue of
the person within it,
kings and all of that.
We're usually like this
with their hands like this,
and they have their swords
near the and all that.
I find that eerie enough to begin with.
But I'm in any case here, uh, the statue,
uh, uh, uh, here,
however the cadaver is the statue,
nature has replaced art or has become art.
Uh, you understand, instead
of having a representation,
you have literally the cadaver
on top of the sarcophagus.
But let us not forget that we are dealing
here with death and also in the realm
of temporality.
If you remember that dude on dark,
his heart was assaulted so
that he would not smell.
How can they cadaver replaced
the statue and not rot?
Like it's hard.
Art has been taken over by death
to this is what the intonation is.
Nothing, not even art is immune from
death. In this world of the cave,
there may be a pun,
a ghoulish pun and bedded here.
Sarcophagus comes from the Greek circles,
flesh and fog line to eat this,
our cover covetous,
literally eats flesh the flesh of
the dead body that it contains.
But here,
the dead body has escaped to become
its own statue is a very baroque image.
We will meet who will find a
another, a sarcophagus, uh,
that we will be discussing in the
course of the next few chapters.
Now their stories and images Montesinos
cave highlight the central topic of part
two deaths in Ganja.
This in Ganja as we have seen,
can mean the destruction of all illusions.
Where Gnocchi haughty comes to
after emerging from the cave,
he declares in what is a classic
expression of, of this and Ganja,
and this is the quote for
give you friends. He tells,
he tells the scholar and central for
having brought me away from the most
pleasing and charming life on site
that ever mortal saw or lived in short.
I am now thoroughly satisfied that all
the enjoyments of this life pass away
like a shadow or a dream and fade
away like the flower of the field.
Oh, on happy Montesinos
all desperately wounded.
[inaudible] or unfortunate Belaroma oh,
weeping.
What the honor and the unlucky daughters
or Rivera whose water show what floods
of tears stream from your fair eyes.
He says a bit later, quote,
I awakened and found myself.
I knew not by what means in the midst
of the finest pleasant test and most
delightful meadow that nature could
create all of the most pregnant fancy
imagine unquote, this is the
locals Aminos of Renaissance, uh,
uh, pastoral literature that
I have mentioned before.
Remember the locals on
Menos into which, uh, uh,
Rocinante wonders and falls in love with
the mayors and all of that. Uh, it is,
it is a topic of renaissance literature
as the most pleasant of places.
And this is where he, where he lands
a person would be where he has,
uh, his, his dream, the same Gagnon was,
I've been saying means to peel
away the illusion that dilution.
It is a form of self analysis
of recognition comparable
to the one in today's
terms achieved through psychoanalysis.
Loki Quixote seems to have
dived into his own subconscious.
Is this a regresses at Ulta Room?
An atavistic returned to the
wound as a Latin way of saying it.
Return to the womb progress was Altarum
is an atavistic return to the womb.
I mean there's, uh, we're trying
to get back into the mother's room,
uh, uh, seeking solace and refuge.
A donkey. Houghton
descent, as we have seen,
makes him look harshly upon himself.
It does not completely shake his
beliefs or dispel his madness,
but it is a serious blow.
And from now on,
he will act saner.
How can it have been pressurable?
However,
only if one thinks that once in the cave,
he was at least in the living
presence of his fictions,
this was pleasurable and
that the disillusionment, uh,
became repressed as he experienced it.
When he met,
when he met all of these elements
that threatened his exists illusions,
we repress them immediately. And that, uh,
as we tend to repress on
unpleasant experiences, uh,
that he was not aware of,
we readers are that what he
experienced threatened his beliefs.
So when he comes, he comes back
with doubts but are not, uh,
conscious, uh, doubts. Now,
everything seems to converge in the
scene of the casinos gave Toki hottest
believe in the authenticity
of the romances of chivalry
and the reality of what
he sees when he sees windmills.
For instance, uh, uh, our,
our question,
the topics of courtly love of
the courtly love tradition,
which had filtered into the romances
of chivalry Tombow through literally
session by there being put through
the requirements of natural law.
I already alluded several times,
would undoubtedly salted heart.
The LERMA for her part may have looked
under the weather because she had her
menstrual period. No, not really.
It is explained because the
problem was that she is Menopausal,
uh,
real time and it's p and a and
withered periodic bodily functions.
A and aging and decay have crept into
the world of fiction contained in the
cave.
No harsher way to dispel the ideal.
The ideal is of a renaissance beauty
than to imagine her menstruating or going
through menopause. We need
that. She's already aged.
Imagine body cellies
venuses with those problems.
Is it girl task?
Uh, it, it's brilliant. However,
mmm.
To subject these idealizations
to temporality and
temporality here means that
their age or they software,
the menstrual period.
Why would do Sydney,
I need a loan.
He said that need or
necessity is everywhere.
It had been passing the world of magic.
You seem they did by needs and
physical laws and uh, and, and,
and what ensues are a grotesque images?
MMM,
no. The, there,
there are many literary antecedents
of the Cave of Montesinos episode.
And I have already mentioned homer,
Virgil and Dante.
But the originality of the happy salt
is not so much the descent into the cave
as that it reveals donkey halters
subconscious. This is Savannah.
This is way of showing us the night's
mind from within unencumbered,
by recent as such.
It is,
it seems to me a better device than the
soliloquy in Shakespeare or in Calderon,
which are parallel devices
to show what a character, uh,
what a character's thoughts are
to be or not to be and so forth.
And in called their own
imam, he settled. Let me the,
this is from the life is
a dream. Uh, also, uh,
it is also more modern,
unacceptable.
This device in Atlantis
to contemporary readers.
It seems to me because no one goes
around delivering soliloquies that are
perfectly structured.
Rhetorically. I don't. I have you,
I'm sure you haven't heard any
of your friends going around, uh,
delivering soliloquies that
are so poetically well, uh,
will rot.
But telling a dream is a common activity.
Uh,
not only to Flaco analysts may
tell your dreams to your friends
in the episode.
There is a group task combination
of fantasy and not just reality,
but the possible all having to
do with the decay of human flesh.
But as I have suggested,
isn't this also a tale of castration fear?
These are the repressed the
figures in donkey, this mind
Peter Dunn, who was a
very good, uh, Hispanic,
the Britain the British has punished who
taught for many years at the end of his
career at Wesleyan University nearby,
rolled the following in a very
good article on this episode.
Uh,
actually Peter Don wrote this article
in Spanish and I'm translating him into
English.
These are the Baroque in versions
that you can get in this course to.
This is what Peter Dunn said in
my own translation into English.
What is observed in the Cave of
Montesinos episode is Cook's autism.
From the insight he looks at himself in
the mirror of his madness who are comedy
and spectator merge and the enchanter
and the enchanted coalesce far from
offering us an image of eternity.
Montesinos his cave constitutes
a frozen temporality,
Loki hot.
They will have to return to his own
bed and dream the dream of death.
So alone Saki,
Hanno can awaken purged of his dreams
and ready to contemplate himself without
theater in the mirror of eternity.
This is anticipating the death
of our own SOC econo. Uh,
at the end of the book,
Anthony Cascara d an American Hispanic
links the episode to the dream argument
in the guard and make quite a few valuable
observations about don Quixote as a
whole,
particularly about the tire debate about
the relationship between reality and
fantasy.
He says,
I see his engagement as with problems
of skepticism and epistemology and more
specifically with the use of fiction
as a mode of knowledge of the world.
His response to skepticism and two,
its compliment epistemology is to reject
the epistemology while remaining anti
skeptical.
But this is only another way of saying
that its purpose is to affirm the role of
fiction in our relationship to the world,
which it might further be said.
It's an affirmation of the role of
fiction in the task of philosophy.
Cervantes shows that
we relate to the world,
including the world of our own
experiences in ways other than what the
epistemologist called knowledge.
And that all we know of the world cannot
be characterized in terms of certainty.
So Vantis we'll do include the imagination
and dreams within the range of valid
human experience within what we call
the world in the broadest sense.
Free of the cabinets of recent points.
This up in short Cascara the tends
to be done to philosophical in short,
that stories,
that literature are a form of knowledge
on a method of approaching knowledge of
the world and of ourselves and a way
to understand both the worlds and the
workings of our own minds.
Now,
psychoanalysis knows this and this is
the reason why Freud availed himself of
figures like the Oedipus,
a myth to name mental processes and force
a Freud acknowledged that his sources,
uh, in the development and
invention or psychoanalysis, I see,
he was really the inventor of it were
literary on that he learned more from
literature than from the 19th
century science that preceded him.
So the point is that these stories in,
in Montesinos cave show that stories
are valid ways of approaching knowledge,
knowledge of the world,
and knowledge of our own minds.
And this is what this episode I
think suggests brilliantly, uh,
and, uh, independently. And also
of course within the structure,
within the structure of the, uh, uh,
of the novel so much for
the time being, uh, uh,
for the episode of what they've seen us
with cave a to which we will probably
have to allude a number
of times, uh, in the, uh,
in succeeding lectures.
And we move now to the second,
uh, important episode that
I want to discuss today.
And that is a master Peter's puppet show.
No, I uh, uh,
I have made a crude a drawing on the,
uh,
on the blackboard that will
help me, uh, explain, uh, the,
uh, uh, the episode. Uh, it is a sketchy,
I understand it is more Picasso's
and Velasquez, let's put it that way.
Uh, but you can recognize
some of the figures that of
course, as soon as the bus,
I'm Auntie,
that is the speaker,
the boy who speaks about this don Quixote.
That is sanctuary.
And then the rest of the audience,
uh, on, of course the puppet show, uh,
as best as I could render it.
Now
the reappearance of [inaudible] to
establish a second creek continuitive with
part one
other than essential,
the women of Donkey Hilda's house,
the priest and the barber.
He nest is the only character for part
one from part one who comes back in part
two.
If before he ness was a rogue picaresque
author and [inaudible] remember,
uh, uh, material among the
author of Guzman. Farace.
Do you remember that? I said in
that episode of the Galley Slaves,
when he says he has written his life is,
is a matter of [inaudible] it before
he knows what a rogue picaresque author
[inaudible],
he is now a master Peter
and miniature playwright,
a Lopey the Vega in miniature,
remember Lopez [inaudible] enemy
and the great Spanish play right?
The period.
Okay.
As both a and Lopi,
he nest stands for the modern author who's
not an Aristocrat or a cleric and has
to earn a living from his craft.
Nope.
Like to put the,
the Vega and his last name to pretend
that he was aristocratic and he made up
fables about his family and all
of that. But uh, he was not,
uh,
he nest also stands for
him for Cervantes himself.
And the whole episode is like a laboratory
for fiction who carry out experiments
about fiction. I said, run. This
tends to do when we have seen he,
Nancy's Wiley,
does not represent respect
literary tradition or rules
and shows the limitations
imposed by the medium of literature.
Like the imagine friend
of the 1605 prologue.
Remember the imagined friend whom said,
Avantis says,
comes to visit him and helps
him write the prologue.
Please.
Modern author does not have a confession,
a conventional or deep classical
education and has to rely on Compendia and
books are familiar quotations
for his area district. Uh,
Lopa was known for this,
for,
to get his information here and there
and pretend that he had read a lot.
He read a lot, but, uh,
not in the way that humanists had read
a great deal and he made it up the way
that the,
the friend tells of in the prologue.
We just go and get this book and Darren
then just make a list of sources in
alphabetical order. And that's, that's the
way, uh, these modern authors upbringing
now he, Naz has now one I
covered, this is why I have,
well actually I have the
wrong, I covered. Um,
it's supposed to be the left eye that
is covered. So to be true to him,
who we uncovered is I uncover these are
the left die.
He has one cover,
presumably the one that pulled in when
he and made him cross out because he
knows that this is a distinctive trait
that is dangerous for him to display.
He can be spotted, described and
nabbed by the Holly Brotherhood.
So he has to disguise himself.
He's why he has to cover his sort of
his signature, his body signature,
which is that he's crossed eyed,
like having a prominent scar or something.
Remember the description
of him Quixote that the uh,
the trooper reads or when
he's about to arrest him. Uh,
towards the end of Clark one, he has a
description, so I description of he ness.
We'll probably begin by saying he is
crossed height. So he has to cover that.
I uh, to be, uh, to be safe.
He,
he nest is a fugitive from justice.
Remember he is one of the Galley
slaves that Don Quixote set free.
Uh,
so whatever other crimes he committed
to make him be a guy in his life.
He is also, he has also escaped. Hence,
I quote,
I had forgot to tell you,
this is from the book that this same
master Peter had his left eye and almost
half his cheek covered with a patch
of green. Tough ETA is signed,
that something else,
all that side of his face.
That's from the text of the key hot
day but being one eyed as it were,
even if it is faked suggests
fresh restrictions that
impeach or his art because
of his limited perception of reality.
I am sort of glossing over it.
My article in the case book that
you have read presumably by now
this deformity also
makes him look furtive.
Dangerous,
sneaky and of course
aesthetically interesting like
the characters in part one
and those in Belasco his paintings,
he is no
renaissance idealized
model of a man or low,
it is said several times that he's
a Galanta and good looking man,
but he's cross light.
Yeah,
but being uh, yeah, uh, before he,
before he nets converging site access,
distorted reality,
we have gone over this now he lacks depth
perception which is very suggestive to
the show that he will stage at the end.
Okay.
Ironically, by eliminating one eye, he,
Nancy's overcoming the problem
of non converging sidelines.
It is a radical way of doing so,
but now he lacks a perspective.
Remember that the binocular,
bye [inaudible], sorry.
By O'Connor a site
you'll see with two eyes.
Therefore you have the
potentially a double vision.
And they are because of this,
they are in some cultures
a dts that overcome this.
By having a PDL I,
which is an I in the middle of the
forehead that sort of serves to mediate
between this, uh, this, uh, uh, so,
uh,
in the case of Jimenez,
he is by eliminating this eye to have
only one eye and therefore only one
vision. Uh, whereas before,
as a cross eyed, he's, he's,
he's, uh, access, did not meet,
uh,
there was supposed to meet here but they
don't quite meet and therefore he, he,
he saw it in a distorted way. But now
with only one eye, as we know, he loves,
he loses, uh, uh, depth. Now,
the whole episode of the Puppet Theater
is besides yet another critique of Lopa
the Vega,
a protractor experiment on all of my
nieces like that of the Princess Mikami
corner. And not just in literary terms,
they're also in, in pictorial terms,
but as a critique of Lopez said,
run this again,
harps upon the carelessness with which
Lopei use history to write his place.
Remember the episode with a Canon
of Tolo where there was a protractor
discussion and critique of low pay
for just grabbing historical elements,
pell mell without being very faithful to,
uh,
history when donkey hot
protests in the middle of the,
of the show that it is wrong to have more
ringing bells instead of kettle drums.
Master Peter Answers with
what contemporaries were.
Contemporaries were sure. Surely not
to miss an allusion to Lopez away.
It says Senjada Donkey Hartej says,
uh,
he nest it. But someone
from within the, uh,
the public theater do not criticize
upon trifles nor expect that perfection,
which is not B to be
found in these matters.
Are there not a thousand comedies
acting almost everywhere full of us,
many improprieties and blunders.
And yet they run their career with great
success and are listened to not only
with applause but with admiration.
Gabori and let folks talk.
He thought he's now addressing the boy.
Go on boy and let folks
talk for soy filling my bag.
I can note if rep, if I represent more
improprieties than there are in the sun.
Now this is clear and I'll loosen it.
A little bit of us could be made.
I remember that [inaudible]
May, uh, as I mentioned before,
may have been a follower and a
defender of Lobelia. And again,
this is why he wrote his,
his uh,
in his bro look such
insulting comments about this.
Now I said laboratory of my meets just
they show that mindset better and he's
assistant put on is of a conceptual
complicity worthy. They'll ask us,
have left Meninas under spinners,
which you'll have seen here to begin with.
We have the performance of the puppets
is not enough in itself and that mastered
Pieter's figures and props require a
supplemental oral commentary or narrative
executed by his assistant.
This is the assistant,
I put a little balloon here as in comic
books because this is what he's saying.
First you feel me? I'll be allowed to
use his convention from, uh, from comics.
So he needs the supplemental
narrative by the, uh, uh,
through her man. What's
the word? The period. Um,
but the visual and verbal representations
do not harmonize properly on both
donkey Horton, he ness how
to admonish the boy, uh,
who is the authors
supplementary voice over,
he's like a voice over in the film,
but it is the seeds,
the voiceover and the film
images didn't quite niche.
It is a dual performance of the
author's invention that is the author of
invention, which is, he knows
here is manifested in two ways,
um,
which has manifested visually
and orally at the same time,
hoping that they will
compliment each other,
but they do not measure satisfactorily.
Uh,
see if there were an inherent flaw in
the recital that reflects the awkwardness
of the theatrical routine. Very awkward
to represent the stories with this,
uh, material objects that are
ribbons that represent human beings.
So what we have here is a very flawed
combination of the oral and the visual
trying to combine to produce, uh, uh,
a performance is satisfactory
performance to, to,
to to produce me Macy's representation
and it you say critique of me,
basis and representation.
This is what I'm trying to say.
Don't hottest corrections to the boy.
Correction to the boy is significantly
made in the language of geometry as
applied to painting.
Doki holders is here,
Gnocchi hotel said in a loud voice boy,
boy on with your story in a
straight line and leave your curves.
I'm trans versales for Tacoma.
The truth of a fact there is often
need of proof upon proof. Oh cool.
What could seem like a mirror rhetorical
display on the part of the night is on
the contrary of surprising propriety in
the context of the episode because the
whole effect of the puppet
show depends on a visual tone.
Palais lay, yeah. Is a French
expression for the trick. Trump la,
you use it in English.
[inaudible] is a word,
an old word in Spanish
it's the same thing.
[inaudible] we don't use
it anymore in Spanish.
If the French word most of the time,
uh,
but it's based on the visual compilation
or a visual trick based on perspective.
Exactly the way that a
painting is organized according
to geometrical rules and
produce the effect of mass and depth.
Okay.
I hope you follow this. You're magical
rules. In the painting we've talked about,
uh, the, the book by Alberti, uh,
produce the effect of mass and,
and depth by distance.
Master Peter Himself,
by the way,
agrees with Don Quixote and his
admonition to the boy also appeals to the
language of geometry and painting.
Boy, none of your flourishes,
but do what you're gentle.
The gentleman bitch you for that is the
surest way flourishes is DBU host or
drawings in the original Loki Houghton,
he needs his word.
Where does it say more than they know
a common occurrence instead of one.
As we have seen many times,
the puppet shows effect.
It's very similitude is
based on a question of
proportions and perspective and
has a great deal to do with a straight
line that don Quixote demands that the
boy not radar follow with
or without much success.
It's a metaphor of to apply
straight line to how a story unfolds
and narrative unfolds. Uh, uh,
the narrative straight line and the
straight line that can be drawn from the
spectators to the show are related,
but it's,
this is the straight
line that the spectators,
uh, from the spectators to
the show as they look at it.
And I'm relating that to the straight
line in the story that Don Quixote refers
to when he admonishes the boy,
if the spectators looked directly at
the theater to engage in it's fantasy,
they have to disregard that are such
a short distance. Human figures,
horses and buildings should appear so
small as if they were much further away.
Perspective has to be
assumed and it's, uh, uh,
uh,
as if different geometric relations
between the public and the tiny actors
obtained as if,
as if the geometric physical relations
between the spectators on the show where
we're different than they
are because they're so close.
The narrator goes through curves and
transverse souls as [inaudible] calls them
to achieve the illusion of simultaneous
action taking place and to hold the
spectators attention and approval in the
same way that the theater has to abuse
the rules of geometry to
stage the action abusive,
the rules of geometry to stage the action
in what is presumably a lot greater
territory, but it is compressed
on the stage. Uh, and,
and the proportion between the
various elements about the various,
the actors on the horses and all of
that is cost. They're not follow,
he knows cannot vary the figures,
dimensions as they come closer
or further away from the public.
They are the dimensions are it
given that cannot be changed.
These whole ensemble of virtual lines
like those in Velasquez is painting,
hold up the fiction and it's preps at
the same time in front of the audience,
the audience,
your hindsight where both of the fixture,
I didn't have the props that are there
to make up the fiction is what I'm trying
to say.
[inaudible]
Velasquez paintings to sustain the
illusion that narrate or not only avails
himself figuratively of the,
of the geometric figures,
but also of the rhetoric of vicious
repeating the Anaphora like a sun.
Anaphora is a rhetorical figure when
you repeated work or a turnoff race.
Let us not forget that the letters not
for good as an owner or rater will repeat
something like that.
That is an Anaphora.
And here the, the the language of
visions in medieval literature.
Use this figure and the
boy says, pray, observe,
see him. Now turn your
eyes door. Now behold,
did you not see behold,
now observe that what he's really telling
them we all have these reputations is
but don't actually see, but don't
actually see what is really happening.
Overlook it. To be able to, uh,
accept the fiction within
the very illusion of a show.
We have a kind of mirror duplication of
the problem of perspective and vanishing
point.
Remember that I talked about vanishing
point in Las Meninas about that gentleman
who's at the very end who is
literally leaving and vanishing.
So that would seem to be a pawn. There it,
this becomes a literal,
when, uh, uh, mainly Sandra,
I'm Dongo Pharaohs who I on the same
horse and gallop desperately running away
from the Moore's doors.
La Linea,
the Franzia towards the line dividing
France from Spain, the border.
So if they are in the horse here, they're
moving towards the back of the stage.
Doors are vanishing point.
So this is literalized here,
the vanishing point in the fiction
that is being depicted in the story.
Okay?
Now all these tricks managed to
confuse Gnocchi hotel of course,
who predictably lunges tours the action
to participate in it caught in a net of
rhetorical under your magical
figures that have blinded him,
not letting him see the difference in
size between his own body and those of his
enemies.
He has lost the sense of proportion and
this is what encourages him other than
his madness, of course, to participate
in the action. This is, by the way,
this scene of Don Quixote, uh, launching
onto this, onto the, onto the, uh,
the stage is one is the one
that Orson Welles used in his,
attempted a film on Becky Haughty.
Orson Welles never finished his Quixote,
but there are parts that he filmed and uh,
I spoke about them in a symposium on
nursing wards here a couple of years ago.
Um, got to see some of them. And
this is one of them. And what he has,
the scene takes place in a movie,
a movie that has been shown.
Our doors actually declined from the
stage and flashes of the screen, uh,
in this, uh, in this, uh, modern
adaptation of this famous scene.
I think that's a rant. This, uh,
project himself in Hyannis Master Peter
as author of modern fictions as he had
already done in the galley
slaves episode in part one.
Do not overlook that.
Cervantes was also a main like, uh, uh,
um, he missed his, a
cross EIT and Cervantes,
as you remember,
had a
leash on his left arm that he could use.
He Nas mattered.
Peter is struggling with the hardships
of authorship as it were by adjusting his
ability to perceive reality,
hence to represent it,
making himself one I'd mastered.
Peter Manages to prevent the problems
created by his gross eyedness.
Remember that with two eyes,
let alone their being cost.
There are two visions which
may or may not coincide,
but we certainly will not if he's
crossed eyed. We have gone over this.
This is the cost of,
is not being able to foresee and ending
to his autobiography. Remember he says,
how can my but autobiography we finished
in my life is not. You could see,
you could project that as, as,
as a problem of vision to if,
if autobiography goes this way and life
that way and you have a vision that
doesn't allow for a, uh, um,
a coincidence of the two,
uh, that, uh, infinitely receding, uh,
end of the, of the, of
the fiction or infinity,
the end of his life could be seen
as part of his, uh, uh, problems,
uh, problems with his eyes. Um,
uh, with only one eye.
However, master Peter,
Peter would be able to look straight
through only one visual axis.
But this is not a happy solution either
to compensate for his loss of one half
of the visual field. He
must look sideways. If he,
if he has his eyes covered, he has
to look sideways to skew in his head.
They cannot achieve a harmonious vision
and he makes himself more awkward.
And uh, an interesting, uh,
Hennessy cannot represent reality
properly with only one eye master.
Peter cannot create a perspective that
would correspond to reason to follow our
Burtis treaties.
In on painting that I mentioned,
he's reading of literary tradition. He's
also a skew like the tilt of his head.
We also know that with only one eye he
would also news his depth perception,
which will disasters. They affect
his capacity to create perspective.
He's rewriting of the municipality Cindra
and Gay Pharaoh stories fraught with
errors like Lopa the Vegas place,
which Don Quixote tries to correct us.
We sold only that ideal reader alone.
So who instead of writing
romances of chivalry,
tried to act one out,
can see straight in the lucid nights of
his library and perceive fixtures that
are harmonious and very similar
within themselves and to himself.
Donkey halting the darkness of one
pal is in, by slashing the Wineskins,
makes the various fictional
levels converged and resolve
the conflicting stories.
It is the ability to fuse all those non
converging levels of fiction that makes
it Ranta switch.
A great modern author who's fictions will
not destroy themselves from within as
he Nessus does here.
Cervantes is a,
is a happy cross eyedness because
the various lines do not feel in his
imaginative world yet
here in some way to him,
the origin of vision is always already
a double vision with irony being
congenital to it with
representation depending on it.
I like to see this whole
episode of Master, uh,
Peters puppet show as an allegory of the
whole of the Quixote which surrounded
the author hidden, uh, inside there.
Um,
uh,
but outside it's fiction which he
controls through strings with the voice
projected by an agent,
a CD.
I met Dave Haley or his translators
whom we cannot quite control either.
The story itself like that of merely
Sandra and guy pharaohs is drawn from
literary tradition but distorted and
rearranged as needed. And the public. We,
the readers drawn into this fiction
are drawn into this friction but not
completely aware as we are of the
artifice of the whole construct.
I am moved,
uh,
romantic that I am we Cervantes
identification with Inez,
the fugitive from justice roaming through
Spain's struggling to make a living
with this facts,
fiction making contraption.
Now Cervantes wraps up this take on
modern literature and his labors in the
brilliant scene that closest the
episode of master beater's puppet show,
the one in which aided by
central on the innkeeper,
Don Quixote compensates the puppeteer
for the figurines that he has smashed.
The value of which broken piece depends
on his or her relative importance in the
fiction,
not on its material value based
on the stuff of which it is made.
Plus the workmanship.
Charlemagne is worth a great deal
because of who he is in this story.
For instance, the real and the fictional
worlds cut through each other here.
Real money is being paid
in restitution for damages,
but the amount of the compensation
is figured on fictional values.
You understand what I mean?
I mean a slave or a or a
peasant or a servant would not.
A figure in even if it's beautiful and
big would not cost as much as that of the
king. What's Advantis seems to be
underlining here is the value of fictional
characters as creations by their author.
How much would I don't Quixote or
essential be worth to Cervantes how much a
hamlet to Shakespeare,
how much would it take to compensate
Garcia Marquez for Colonel Aureliano when
Dhea or [inaudible] for a Pierre Menard,
these are fictional entities,
but now they have a real monetary
value in a world in which literature is
becoming a commodity without
ceasing to be at the same time,
one of the great expressions of the human
spirit that this scene is reminiscent
of the one in part one we're a torsion
when restitutions are made to the barber
who's based in,
has been taken to the innkeeper for
expenses and damages and marriage vows are
exchange to make up for Fernando's
this honest behavior toward the repair.
It is a miniaturised
scene of restitutions,
a small scale repetition of
that scene in part one to me,
it is as if Savannah Savannah's we're
boasting or how many ways you can rewrite
rewrite episodes in part two and he is
certainly a master puppeteer himself.